sur l'exploitation de la famille bête
200 vaches qui produisent du lait leurs
réserves de nourriture se trouve ici
dans des silos d'ensilage sous ses pneus
usagés il y en a près de 100 tonnes
les éleveurs se les procurer auprès des
cars hagist mais au fil du temps ils
sont devenus beaucoup moins pratique
c'est pas très esthétique leur
dégradation mais génère des des soucis
en terme de maniabilité il se dégénère
les pneus se dégénère laissant
apparaître des ferrailles
donc c'est dangereux pour nous et c'est
dangereux pour les animaux
certaines déchetterie
locale n'en veulent pas lorsque l'on
souhaite les faire de les faire éliminer
de manière massive c'est très goûteux
comptait 300 euros la tonne
d'où l'intérêt de l'association ans yves
alors créé par le ministère de la
transition écologique et les acteurs de
la filière du pneu grâce à leur
contribution
l'éleveur devra débourser au final 75
euros la tonne le dépôt se fait dans des
coopératives agricoles comme ici à la
capr aux gars de chez elle puis les
pneus seront acheminés par une
entreprise spécialisée pour de la
valorisation énergétique la filière
aliapur est organisée elle pour faire
broyer les pneumatiques et les faire
brûler dans les cimenteries les
pneumatiques
en termes de qualité de caoutchouc sont
complètement dégradée par le temps et
donc son ne sont pas réutilisables dans
le loiret la prochaine collecte est
prévue à l'automne
objectif récupérer cette année 400
tonnes de pigments c'est de l'écologie
discrète si on peut l'appeler comme ça
mais c'est l'écologie c'est du recyclage
intelligent de matières dont on ne sait
plus quoi faire aujourd'hui et qui
embarrasse sur les exploitations les
alternatives aux pneus existe il ya par
exemple des sacs remplis de sable ou de
gravier et cette transition a forcément
un coût financier